- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today, we're going to talk about
how to succeed on social media.
And as always, as you're
watching the video,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below,
put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired
and when you write it down,
you're much more likely to lock it in
for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(bright music)
- The mood that I have
and the thing that I want
to talk to you about today,
and the variable of the
difference of the companies
that win it and lose, and
the reason big companies
go out of business, like Blockbuster
and Woolworth's, and things of that nature
is that the only thing I do
is I market in the actual
(bleep)ing year we live in.
(audience cheering)
What I'm concerned about when I look
at the behavior online
of 99% of this room,
and when I say this room,
let's throw everybody into it.
The Fortune 500 companies I work with,
all the startups, 99% of people
are marketing like it's 2008,
2004, 2002,
1997, 1994.
And that, my friends, is the disconnect.
The reason most people
are giving up dollars
and aren't relevant is
they're not storytelling
in the year that we actually live in
because that takes storytelling
where people's attention is.
The number one thing that
connects to every single person
in this room is we're all
battling for somebody's attention.
Before you could tell me how great you are
and how my life is going to be so legit
if I get into this, or
why it's so delicious,
or way healthier, before
you tell me all that stuff,
you need to get my attention.
The internet
is the gateway drug to
one-on-one relationships.
Let me say it again.
Because I know there's a lot
of old school folks in here
and listen, I'm an old school folk.
There's a lot of old
school folks that say,
"Yeah, this new stuff, and it's sad,
"and everybody's on their phone..."
But we're a business that's built on
one-on-one relationships.
Let me tell you something,
I've scaled the (bleep) out
of one-on-one relationships
with this thing right here.
And if you do not understand that
engagement online is the gateway
to one-on-one relationships
in our world today,
you are missing the culture
shift we're living in.
- I think by far, the
biggest tip I can give you is
to post more frequently.
Many brands assume they should only post
once or twice a day on
Facebook or Twitter,
and I think that's just wrong.
My Twitter account has like,
75 to 80 posts per day.
Google Plus has five, Facebook has five.
So that's, you know,
that's 80, 100 posts a day.
And my assumption is that
not everybody who's
interested in my content
is awake at the same time,
and even if they are
awake at the same time,
they may have different
consumption habits.
Some people read in the morning,
some people at lunch,
some people at night,
so, yes, you will, when
you post more and more,
you'll get people complaining
that you're posting too much,
you're a spammer, you
know, blah blah blah.
But I can tell you, for
example, with Twitter,
I literally repeat my tweets three times,
eight hours apart.
And I track it with a bitly
link and I can tell you,
the first time I tweet, I get X clicks.
The second time I get X
and the third time I get X,
so, you can either have X
clicks or three X clicks
and, you know, my attitude is,
okay, some people are upset with that.
That's just the cost of doing business.
You know, the goal of social media is
not to not piss off anybody.
The goal of social media is to
create a very marketing
and powerful platform,
so that's my number one tip
to brand using social media.
- To get a big following,
you have to read every day.
You know, I wake up in
the morning, personally,
and I read, I read inspiring things,
I'll read some Emerson,
I'll read some, a lot of
philosophy about life,
I'll read some narratives or biographies
of people who inspire me.
I get my mind in the morning,
whether it's on poetry,
or philosophy, or a political figure,
something that inspires me to
be thinking in a bigger way.
That's what I do every day.
I think it, your following
ultimately comes from
how big you're thinking it is.
You know, if you're just micromanaging
and living in one little world,
as much as they want you
to be a niche marketer,
no, we want you to be a thought leader.
There's a big difference,
are you a niche marketer,
or are you a thought leader?
And I choose thought leadership
and I think it's valuable,
I think it's important for you to
be broadening your own mindset,
your own philosophy about life,
or business, or career,
or whatever it is your topic is,
and be broadening that by
reading more in that area
because reading more will
make you more creative.
And you already know, you
know, readers are leaders,
leaders are readers, and so,
you got to be reading things that digest
in your mind that all of a sudden
will come out in a creative
thought or a creative act.
And it's those creative thoughts
and acts get you followed
online.
- The real funny thing to
me in the world right now
is that everybody is
full of (bleep), right?
And what I mean by that is
when you look at people
tweeting or Facebooking,
they're trying to disguise
their ask by being witty.
Right? Meanwhile, the one
thing I know more than anything
is that our collective
bull(bleep) radars today
compared to 15 years ago,
are dramatically better, and the kids,
(bleep), their bull(bleep)
radars are excelling.
They just know it, right?
So, what I've been testing a lot of
and believe a lot of value in is
jab, jab, jab, right hook.
Give people value and funny stories,
give them an animated GIF that
just makes them laugh, right?
That just makes, say happy Monday.
It's fine. You don't
need a business objective
for every piece of creative.
Because we live in a world now
where it's not just about campaigns,
where you do two or three of them
and you spend all your money,
you live in a world where
we're doing it every day.
A lot of it.
And so, we have the freedom,
the creative freedom
to actually act human, and
bring a little value to them,
bring value, bring value, bring value.
Respond, engage, bring value,
make it funny, make it newsworthy.
And then, let's all become
grown ups once and for all
and recognize we can ask for the business
if we're just authentic about it.
A funny thing happens when
you give a (bleep)load
of value up front, you guilt
people into buying (bleep).
(audience laughing)
And so, like, give value, give value,
act human, do the right thing, answer,
be there for them, have good,
everybody on like, Twitter,
everybody thinks you have to be funny
on Twitter like, funny is
like the one characteristic
that works out.
Everything works on Twitter,
it's a human platform,
but the problem is,
most people don't want
to be self-deprecating
or have empathy or be kind,
like, there's not that many.
And nobody wants to put it out there,
they think they want to put out something
that gets retweeted.
How about we listen instead
of talk? People like that.
Think about the friend
that you would rather call
instead of the friend
that always calls you,
and then think about who
you want to hang out with.
Right? And so we have to act
human, we have to bring value,
and then you say, value, value, value,
and then you say, I
wrote a (bleep)ing book.
Right? And that's kind
of the science, you know,
boxing is known as a sweet science,
that's why I use this metaphor
for titles, how I think.
I'm spending all my time and
energy and I highly recommend
whatever energy you're spending on this,
you spend more because the attention,
they eyes, the ears of our consumers,
they're clearly going in these places.
They're clearly going in these places,
and if we do not figure out the art
and the science of how to
actually storytell to them,
not use them as just distribution,
realize how stupid it is
to use the same picture
on Instagram, Facebook,
Twitter, and Tumblr,
realize that, understand
there's a real science in this,
a real storytelling
battle going on right now
in these platforms, and understanding that
you as an individual act differently
when you go into a boardroom
in a business meeting
than you would when you go with your girls
to Las Vegas for the weekend,
than when you would when you
go out with your boyfriend.
You're still the same person
but the context of the room
changes the way you storytell.
- I think that there are
a few things to look at
when you're trying to
master say, social media.
And that is that social media is, in fact,
very, very broad and
you should be specific
and choose one or two tools to focus on.
And by that, I mean,
if you have a toolkit,
if you want to be a good carpenter,
you focus on one tool at a time.
And similarly, I wouldn't
try to become an expert
at Facebook, Twitter, Linkedin,
Tumblr, Wordpress, all simultaneously,
choose one depending on the format where
you feel most effective
and that you enjoy.
You still need that enthusiasm
to fuel you through all
the learning curves.
And then focus on that.
In my particular case, I use the blog,
which is Wordpress based,
and I focused on typically
500 to 1500 word pieces.
Developed that as my heartbeat,
this is a very important concept,
that was my Grand Central Station,
and if I did anything on
say, Facebook or Twitter,
it either was to broadcast
the things I found
interest or value to my readers,
or to bring them to content
that was on the blog.
And that was the center of the heartbeat.
So, focus on one thing at a time.
And I think in life, as in social media,
you can have it all,
you just can't have it
all at the same time.
- Primary lesson that's hard for me
to get into people's brains
who want to learn about business
or improving their financial situation is
you go straight to the top.
What most people do is they find a, like,
if you want to grow your
Instagram, you find a friend
who has a thousand more
Instagram followers
and you're like, oh, I'm
going to get a tip from them.
Forget that, go straight to
the top, who has the most.
Taylor Swift has 50.7
million Insta followers,
it takes the same amount of time in day
to learn from Taylor Swift's Instagram
as it does, you know, from your brothers
or your uncles or something like that.
And I think the reason, and
this implies not just to
growing your social media following,
I'll talk about that in a second,
some things that I've learned
to grow social following,
but this implies to all there is in life.
You want to learn how to play basketball?
Go watch old Michael Jordan videos.
You want to learn how to lift weights?
Go watch some old Arnold
Schwarzenegger stuff,
some Lee Haney stuff.
You want to learn to be
healthy? Find somebody who's a,
you know, supermodel or something.
I got a friend who's one
of the top male models
of the world, the dude
has like, an eight pack.
Hang out with him, you
go straight to the top,
don't be intimidated and
don't sell yourself short.
Back to the subject of growing
a social media following,
to me, nowadays it's all
about a couple things:
it's all about lifestyle marketing,
and lifestyle growth.
You know, people want,
people ask me, "Tai,
"you got this big house, like,
"why can't you afford a
selfie stick or a tripod?"
Well, I actually do have
a tripod right there,
but a lot of things people engage better,
I've tested it, people
want to know, it's like,
having a face-to-face conversation.
So, make sure social media
is not too stiff and stuffy,
you know? Make sure,
like, The Office TV show, some of you saw,
I know Dwight Schrute, Rain Wilson,
he was here at the house, I don't know,
a week or two ago and we
were talking about how
The Office, they would use these cameras
which made it feel like you
were in the actual office
with Steve Carrel and
you know, Dwight Schrute
and all these funny guys.
And so, it upped their ratings,
they did 202 episodes.
So, whether it's TV,
whether it's Instagram,
even your video, even your
entrepreneurial growth
can be fueled by this reality
slash lifestyle branding.
So, I mean, you know,
I got YouTube videos I've done,
a lot of views, 60 million
views that were done like this.
And how was that, how did I kind
of come to that realization?
Well, it was by following
people straight to the top,
even if you look at a
lot of these big people,
whether it's, you know, Taylor Swift,
or Ariana Grande has a big following,
and you look at the
engagement of which pictures
and which videos get the most
engagement on their social,
that's information gathering sessions.
You sit there and you stare
at it and you're like,
"Wait a sec, that
picture that's all formal
"with the photographer that's all stiff,
"that one got, you know, 50,000 likes
"and this one where it's just like,
"her like, with a camera
going like, what's up!
"That one did 75,000."
Boom, clue revealed,
clue reveals the answer
right there to you so...
- So, I have a couple quick
thoughts on social media
that I wanted to share
and how to have success.
Number one is you have
to define your outcome.
It's important to know
what you want out of this.
Are you trying to build a personal brand?
Are you trying to sell
your product or service?
Are you trying to just
have a form of escape
just to get away from your busy life
and you want to connect with your friends?
Understanding why you're on the platform
will help you devise a strategy to win.
Number two is find your voice.
It's really important
that you understand that
there is nobody else like you.
There's a lot of other people out there,
they have their own
opinions, their own voices,
but you're not going to succeed
by just being a copy of somebody else.
Your ultimate success will come by you
finding your own voice
and putting out content
that you resonate with that
other people aren't
saying those exact things.
And so at the beginning, this is hard.
At the beginning, you don't
know what your voice is,
at the beginning, you're still
trying to figure it all out.
And so, I think it's actually okay
to copy people at the start.
It's okay to copy somebody's
style of making videos,
or making tweets, or
making Instagram pictures.
It's okay to copy.
And in that process, you
learn about yourself.
You need to understand, though,
that your ultimate success won't come
by copying somebody else.
You will never be massively successful
by just being a junior
version of somebody else
so, a lot of people copy my
video style, as an example.
They make their own top 10 rules
or their own versions of what I'm doing.
And that's okay, it doesn't bother me.
They're never going to have the success
that I'm having if
they're just copying me.
But what it allow you to
do, by coping those people,
is then see, hmm, I like that,
I like what Evan's doing,
I like what Gary's doing,
I like what Jimmy is doing,
I like what Susan is doing.
But I want to twist it up a little bit.
And that's where you're
going to have success.
When you take what is
working for somebody else,
and then you twist it
and add some flavor to it
that only you can add.
Because you can never out-Evan Evan,
and I can never out-you you.
So, go be you! That's
how you're going to win.
You need to find your voice.
And number three is is be prolific.
It's important that if you were trying
to achieve a real outcome,
and you're trying to build a brand,
you're trying to sell product,
that you are prolific in
the creation of the content.
You're not going to get really great at it
if you're doing something once a week.
You're just not going to
get really good at it.
Try learning anything once a week
without practicing in between,
you're never going to
get really good at it.
If you're trying to pick up salsa dancing,
or you want to learn Spanish,
or you want to play the piano,
if you're only doing it once a week,
you're never going to get really,
really, really good at it.
You need to be more prolific.
The quantity leads to the quality.
The practice leads to you
getting good at something,
and so, back to number one,
if you have you a goal, if
you have a business objective,
and this is important to you
that you have success with it,
then you need to dedicate
time for you to learn it,
to get good at it, to practice,
to practice, to practice.
To be prolific, so that
you can find your voice,
and create content that
really touches people.
So, those are my thoughts on social media,
those are some of the thoughts
of the experts in the field.
I made this video because
the Darth Reaper asked me to.
So, if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover
in the next edition of Believe Life,
leave it down in the comments
and I'll see what I can do.
I'm also curious to figure out
what did you like most about this video?
What lesson are you going
to immediately apply
to your life, to your
business, after watching this?
And why are you on social?
What is your outcome,
what is your objective?
Are you doing it for personal
development, to try to learn?
Are you trying to build
a brand and sell product?
Is it just an escape from your busy life
and you want to be entertained?
Super curious to figure that out.
Leave it in the comments, I'm
going to join the discussion.
I also just want to give a
quick shoutout to Nilmarly,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and posting that review
on your Facebook page,
I really, really, really appreciate it
and I hope that it's had a
good impact on your life.
So, thank you guys so much for watching,
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love, have an amazing
day. I'll see you soon.
- It's just not how, what was the ROY
being on the cover of Ink?
- Great question.
- You know, to me,
the answer is it's got to be something,
it's a lot of impressions and awareness
that may get them into
the rabbit hole of me.
They saw me at the
airport, they saw the Ink,
they Google me, they read my Wikipedia,
they follow me on
Twitter, seven days later,
I put out a good slideshare,
nine days later, I ask
them to buy the book
from a right hook on Twitter.
They buy it, ROY to Ink.
But how you're going to quantify that
is insanity, and so I think social media
has been asked to create an ROY
that every other medium hasn't
or hasn't since they've been accepted.
Right? Television went through this.
In the '50s and '60s, wait a minute,
this TV thing, what's the ROY,
we know what radio and print does.
So, it's the same old
game, this is historic.
I mean, we can be having this meeting,
I wish I was older, and I
wished that I was on the scene
back in '95, six, seven, when
I talked about e-commerce
because all the same questions.
How are you going to compete
with Walmart and K-Mart
and JC Penney's?
And Barnes and Nobles and
Borders and Walden Books,
how is this Amazon thing going to compete,
I was laughing at people to the notion,
and clearly that's played out
over the last two decades.
I think we'll look back at what's the...
The ROY of anything that
gets in front of the consumer
where they actually spend their time,
here's what I know: everybody
who's watching right now,
they do this for a living.
And if you don't know how
to get into this screen
and storytell about what
you do for a living,
you're out.
Social networks control
an enormous percentage
of that consumption.
If you don't know how to
storytell in a screen economy
in 2014, I think you're really
playing Russian Roulette
with your advertising dollars.
- You're going to have people around you
in your organization,
and/or you're going to get emails back
saying, oh, this doesn't work,
or this is a waste of time.
Okay? You're also going to
have people tell you back off,
okay, this is not
wanted, or don't spam me,
or you sent me the
wrong, I don't need this,
why'd you send this to me?
This is exactly what happens to all people
that are trying to get attention.
When you get attention at the right level,
the first thing that's
going to happen to you
is you're going to get criticism.
You want to push through the criticism
until you get admiration, you
want to push through more.
It's not any different.
Facebook, Twitter, YouTube,
social media is no different
than me knocking on a door,
saying, hey, I want to sell you a product.
You're going to have people
slamming the door in your face.
The next question go-to,
they're going to say,
get out of my neighborhood,
what are you doing here?
If you stop because of this suppression,
this stop on you, if you stop
because people are asking
you to stop, you're done.
So, the same thing
happens with social media.
Look, when you tweet,
or when you put an entry into Facebook,
the way to take that and
make it unique, okay,
and not spammy,
and not bother people
is to personalize it.
So, consider the people that you've been
trying to sell products
to, not just your friends.
Let's say there was a plumber
you were trying to sell a truck to.
You would want to email
the plumber and say,
Mr. Plumber, I just got a hold of a site
of a sales trainer that
can increase your sales
at your business, Mr. Plumber.
And I wanted to make sure you
have the information there,
I thought of you when I
saw this, and by the way,
I could win $10,000.
And so, could any of your employees
as well as getting
hooked up with a guy that
can increase your sales in this economy
and I thought of you.
So, you got to personalize it
so that it's not spammy.
You can't just keep using that one message
we sent you yesterday which was,
I can win $10,000 and so can you!
Look, that's spammy, that's
why people say that's spammy,
you have to personalize it.
- Do this with heart.
You can't survive doing
this if your art isn't real,
if your heart isn't in the work,
'cause you won't get up in the morning
and be motivated for it,
you won't be excited about it.
You have to have at the base
of all that you're posting,
if people can tell that you care,
you'll be followed.
If people can tell that you care about
values and humanity
and the philosophy of living a good life
and taking care of other
people, respecting other people,
you'll be followed.
You could become a caustic hater
and maybe you'll gather a couple people,
but you're never going
to get millions of people
and if you do, you'll burn out your soul
because nobody wants to live a life
where they're just
criticizing and being a jerk.
Be the positive thought
leader in whatever you do.
Be the most caring. Be
the most consistent.
Be the person who shows up.
And if you'll just show up every day
with the intention to
capture one unique moment,
one unique lesson, one unique story,
one unique quote, one unique picture,
one unique video, whatever it is for you
and your favorite medium,
capture one thing every single day.
You'll be fully energized with your life
'cause life won't just be work anymore,
it's art.